I think the common experience of working
through this extremely demanding program
and working through it in groups
produces relationships and friendships
that last people throughout their entire
management career that you see an
interesting thing happening at reunions
in this school when people come back ten
years later there is not a whole series
of encounters of getting reacquainted
people have a fairly good familiarity
with what has happened to their
classmates over time they've often been
in contact with them on a fairly regular
basis those those people who were in a
section together in the NBA one year
remain a very cohesive tight group when
they come back it's it's almost like
you're revisiting a party in the NBA one
year they're the lots of cohesiveness
lots of friendship lots of togetherness
that happens so the relationships
continue throughout a person's entire
business career and I think that's one
of the real strengths of the program
there's really is a fraternity among
Western grads they tend to stick
together you know you go into for a job
interview and something knows some of
that graduated with you or so it's just
a very very close paternity and they all
seem to stick together and they have
something in common they all went
through the same sort of war together
you know
it just seems to be there I don't know I
I see it here tonight I ran in some
people are educated we're 65 grads I had
nothing in common with him in all his 20
years Deborah or 15 years difference yet
they seem to you know relate to me and I
seen relate to them we had the same sort
of experience together what we're trying
to do is we're trying to converge on the
student the participant his or her
development with the technology we have
with the cases we have with the total
program that we're trying to achieve
because our end goal has a more
effective manager if you give up on
yourself sort of saying I'm never going
to be able to learn this then then
you're defeating your purpose i think
going into the mba I felt fairly
confident the first four months of the
NBA are totally inadequate coming out of
the NBA I felt great and looking looking
at myself now five years out of it I
feel I feel I have a solid background I
feel very self-confident I have no
difficulty talking to clients on
whatever their needs are so I think it
did a lot for me